etienne caux les 20 ans originaire du
chéné n'est pas mécanicien mais un futur
participant au 4l trophy un raid 100
pour 100 étudiants entre la france et le
maroc
cet élève de l'école d'ingénieurs estaca
prendra le départ de cette 20e édition
avec son ami depuis dix ans killian
hennebelle pour participé 7000 euros ont
été nécessaires pour financer les frais
d'inscription à la préparation du
véhicule
en parallèle les deux étudiants dû
préparer la fameuse 4l pendant plusieurs
semaines ça soit sur le sponsoring on
n'y a passé plusieurs mois et la
mécanique où il ya toujours quelque
chose qui on démonte une pièce est celle
d'à côté qui va casser donc beaucoup
beaucoup de temps tout le monde peut y
aller si on se fait préparer la voiture
mais généralement recommandés notions de
mécanique parce qu'une 4s à tombent
souvent en panne
moi personnellement je connaissais pas
grand chose avant de commencer on
apprend sur le tas mais on a beaucoup
d'équipages qui nous forme si pendant
leur périple les deux acolytes
embarqueront dans leurs coffres entre
les boîtes à outils des fournitures
scolaires les distribueront tout au long
du parcours en partenariat avec
l'association enfants du désert
la structure permet la scolarisation
d'enfants marocains pour les collecter
les étudiants ont fait des actions de
sensibilisation on a fait une première
organisation avec une école à versailles
on a donné des cours de l'histoire de
voitures à des mécaniques et des enfants
en enseignements pour avoir des
fournitures des parents et on a fait ça
une école il ya 50 ans sur le plan
sportif les rétros pilotes membres de
l'association estac hatrel ne se sont
pas fixé d'objectif et veulent terminer
le plus haut possible
pour cela ils devront batailler face à
2700 pilote le but en fait ce pas une
course de vitesse et une course aux
chauffeurs le moins de kilomètres
possibles donc ça va être vraiment à
l'orientation et on va se prendre au
challenge pense qu'il ya besoin d'elle
vite mais voilà brême d la 4l en entier
ce sera déjà une victoire
le 4l trophy se déroulera du 16 au 26
février le départ sera donné depuis
biarritz cette année plus d'une dizaine
d'étudiants de l'estaca participeront à
la compétition